when people are upset by politics they
either withdraw completely into a cave
of silence or double down engaging more
and more fiercely than ever because it's
easy to get angry when there's so much
at stake but that's exactly why you
shouldn't for this video we're going to
accept to your party politicians and
positions as the right ones which makes
those who disagree wrong and when
they're very obviously very ridiculously
wrong and even proud of it you have a
right to call them what they are
ignorant reckless even dishonest so you
tweet or joke or make a video about it
but here's the problem when was the last
time someone changed your mind after
calling you ignorant reckless or
dishonest and you might say of course it
doesn't change minds it's about standing
up for what's right but living in a
democracy it means their vote affects
you and everyone you know just as much
as yours so if taking a stand is that
important to you well nobody is stopping
you just know that it comes at the cost
of the very policies that you claim to
be taking a stand for a pacifist is
committed to non-violence but a true
believer accepts violence that prevents
greater atrocities that's not abandoning
the principle it's better defending it
because defending a principle means
nothing if doing so actually impedes its
progress and fulfilling your political
goals as best you can may look to an
observer like abandoning them either
people are completely impenetrable to
all persuasion and you need not waste a
single moment convincing them otherwise
that your best interest is to recruit
not to repel
your political wishlist is likely very
long but aim for everything and you'll
probably achieve nothing supporting many
issues may feel like shooting many
arrows increasing the odds that one will
succeed but those outside your party
don't search your brochure for common
ground they gravitate towards your most
extreme arguments no matter how
reasonable your other opinions are one
poorly communicated argument can swallow
them all even if only 5% of your wish
list it'll consume 95% of their
attention every time you talk about
issues a B and C they'll always return
to the more enraging issue D and that's
if you're lucky more likely the media
will take your argument distort and
exaggerate it and watch it spread from
water cooler to water cooler for many
this will be their only exposure to your
arguments and how they know your party
why would I listen to you you're the one
that said that crazy thing never mind
that you never actually said that you'll
know you found your party's issue D when
the opposition spends all their time
talking about it yet it's only a tiny
fraction of your argument and maybe it
really is worth fighting for but it
prevents you from making real progress
anywhere else so you don't need to throw
out all your controversial opinions but
pick and choose which ones you shout so
you don't strike out
for every political issue you should
start anew do the research explore each
side and make a verdict but no one has
time for that thinking through each
issue independently is just not
cost-effective much easier to form a few
key beliefs early in life and use them
as rulers by which all else is measured
taking a position that no longer
requires days of research but a quick
glance at your ruler and as one leads to
another which leads to another and so on
the cost of changing your mind increases
exponentially why are people so
resistant to change opinions on even the
most unimportant topics because doing so
would also require throwing away years
of underlying opinions so the question
is never which is better dogs or cats
but why dogs are better than cats but if
someone is so stubborn they'll follow a
core belief any where it leads them find
a way to justify your policy with their
belief and they'll have no choice but to
follow that's the beauty of their
stubbornness if you're trying to
convince a liberal sprinkle in words
like equality and fairness and for a
conservative pride and duty to prove the
power of words there are places like
change my view where you can go explain
your opinion click Submit and wait for
others to persuade you otherwise if
someone is successful you award them a
delta which to a researcher studying
persuasion is gold because you can take
all these conversations plug them into
some fancy algorithms and see what good
arguments have in common
like for example using less extreme
language effective replies hedge their
arguments with words like perhaps or
it's possible and if you don't convince
someone after four replies you probably
never will in other words the clock is
ticking
as effective as these strategies are
there is an asterisk no matter how far
you push the political boulder forward
it will always eventually fall back down
because behind every bad law and
politician is a bad system that produced
it politicians can be removed and laws
can be retracted but these are band-aids
and pretty bad ones their replacements
will only be more deceptive versions of
the same that's the nature of politics
public anger doesn't make politicians
rethink their values only how carefully
to hide them focusing on individuals is
a recipe for eternal frustration the
only real solution is to change systems
if politics feels like a constant fire
in need of attention the solution is to
figure out what's so flammable whether
that be who can vote how elections are
run or where districts are drawn of
course if all this sounds like too much
work you can always just yell on Twitter
but you may just be campaigning for the
opposition if you enjoyed the section on
how words affect persuasion I think
you'd like a book called the stuff of
thought by Steven Pinker it's about the
interesting things language can tell us
about people and the way we think but as
much as I enjoyed the book it's a pretty
big time commitment that's why I
recommend an app called Glinka
it takes the key insights of thousands
of non-fiction books and condenses them
into a few minutes reading or listening
the stuff of thought is 524 pages but
it's a 15 or 20 minute read with Linkous
another great thing is that it solves
the commitment problem of finishing
books I've often found myself halfway
through a book not really enjoying it
but knowing that I paid for it I try to
finish it anyway with a subscription to
blink hist you can read as many books as
you want so you don't have to feel bad
stopping a book that you're not enjoying
in fact you're incentivized to read more
to maximize its value you can go to
blink Escom slash poly matter AFF or
just click the link in the description
to try it out for free or get 20% off a
subscription doing either one will
directly support this channel so thanks
to everyone who signs up
[Music]
you